die weltgesundheitsorganisation who
warnt deutlich vor einer dringenden
gefahr für die gesundheit des menschen
denn diese bakterien sind sogar gegen
notfall antibiotika resistent wir
menschen sind diesen superkeime also
schutzlos ausgeliefert und die waffen
der medizin werden immer stumpfer die
zahl der todesfälle durch den klebsiella
pneumoniae keim ist in den vergangenen
jahren um das sechsfache angestiegen ein
alptraum
also für jedes ärzteteams und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nicht
herzlich willkommen
resistente keim mit der bezeichnung
klebsiella pneumoniae hat schon zwischen
2012 und 2013 an der uniklinik in
leipzig ja man muss sagen sein
schreckliches unwesen getrieben bei mehr
als 100 patienten und patientinnen wurde
der erreger damals nachgewiesen eine
lange erkrankung serie folgte und
achtung mindestens 30 menschen starben
und die infektionsgefahr durch diese
bakterienart wächst in europa rasant
denn der extrem resistente
krankheitserreger verbreitet sich
superschnell und dabei macht er auch vor
landesgrenzen keinen halt einer früheren
studie zufolge ist die zahl der
todesfälle durch diesen erreger vom jahr
2017 bis zum jahr 2015 um das sechsfache
gestiegen in absoluten zahlen
ausgedrückt von 340 auf knapp 2100
todesopfer jetzt hat ein forschungsteam
in einer aktuellen untersuchung
analysiert wie sich die erreger genau
ausbreiten dazu schauten sich die
fachleute die genome von mehr als 1700
extrem resistenten klebsiella pneumoniae
isolaten aus 244 krankenhäusern in 32
ländern an darunter auch aus deutschland
demnach sorgen nur wenige gene für die
meisten resistenzen und zwar indem sie
bestimmte enzyme produzieren lassen
diese machen dann das eingesetzte
antibiotika unschädlich und nicht nur
das auch die sogenannten
reserveantibiotika die nur dann
eingesetzt werden wenn andere
antibiotika versagen helfen dann oft
nicht mehr in der fachsprache ist die
rede von xtr das steht für extreme drug
resistant und heißt übersetzt so viel
wie extrem resistente bakterien in
diesem worst case szenario gibt es dann
für medizin teams nur noch die
möglichkeit auf experimente
oder sehr alte antibiotika
zurückzugreifen doch diese sind mit
vielen nebenwirkungen verbunden und
helfen keinesfalls immer und so gibt es
immer wieder menschen die an
bakteriellen infektionen sterben und
zwar unter den augen von ärzten und
ärztinnen die verzweifelt ein
antibiotikum nach dem anderen
verabreichen und das ohne erfolg so wie
bei einer patientin aus den usa vor drei
jahren ein typisches beispiel sie war
eigentlich nur mit einem knochenbruch
ins krankenhaus gekommen
doch die klebsiella pneumoniae kein
breiteten sich in ihrem körper aus
insgesamt hatte das medizinerteam es mit
ganzen 26 antibiotika versucht doch ohne
erfolg
am ende war die patientin tod der fall
zeigt in aller deutlichkeit wie
gefährlich die l ab neu moni wirklich
ist das helmholtz zentrum für
infektionsforschung bezeichnet den
erreger als einen der gefährlichsten
krankenhauskeime überhaupt er kann lange
zeit im menschlichen darm überleben ohne
überhaupt symptome zur zeit
problematisch denn die infektion bleibt
so lange zeit unentdeckt zudem sind neue
infektionen sehr wahrscheinlich
spezieller pneumoniae ist extrem
widerstandsfähig und vermehrt sie
schnell zudem ist es auch extrem
hartnäckig wie ein fall im jahr 2011 in
einem us krankenhaus zeigte nach der
ersten infektion wurden zwar isolierung
maßnahmen eingeleitet doch diese waren
keinesfalls ausreichend der ausbruch
forderte im laufe weniger monate sechs
todesopfer doch einem ergebnis der
aktuellen studie kann man auch etwas
positives abgewinnen denn das risiko
sich den superkeim im alltag zu holen
ist nicht besonders groß zur
überraschung des forschungsteams gingen
70 prozent aller proben auf nur vier
erreger linien zurück und diese
verbreiten sich vor allem in
krankenhäusern also an den orten wo
viele antibiotika eingesetzt werden zum
großer befanden sich in den
verschiedenen proben eines krankenhauses
varianten die sich genetisch ähnlich
sind dazu der wissenschaftler hajo
grundmann aus freiburg der an der studie
beteiligt war die genetischen
unterschiede zwischen extrem resistenten
isolaten nahmen zu je größer die
entfernung zwischen den krankenhäusern
war
unsere beobachtungen sprechen dafür dass
sich extrem resistente bakterien vor
allem innerhalb einzelner krankenhäuser
sowie bei der verlegung von patienten
zwischen geografisch nahe liegenden
krankenhäusern verbreiten
eine weitere wichtige erkenntnis des
forschungsteams ist dass diese erreger
besonders häufig dort auftreten wo sehr
oft sogenannte reserve antibiotika
verordnet werden das ist vor allem in
südeuropa der fall hinzu kommt das
ergebnis dass die erreger sich umso
besser
in krankenhäusern verbreiten resistenter
sie sind das bakterium wird dabei nicht
nur von mensch zu mensch übertragen
sondern wird auch über den kontakt mit
kontaminierten also von dem erreger
befallenen oberflächen verschleppt eine
amerikanische untersuchung offenbart und
vor einiger zeit dass die erreger auch
in beatmungsgeräten schlummerten die
bereits mehrmals desinfiziert worden
waren dass autoren und autorinnen team
rät also zur vorsicht wenn patienten und
patientinnen gerade in einem krankenhaus
behandelt worden sind dazu heiko
grundmann
es ist extrem wichtig patienten bei der
aufnahme nach früheren krankenhaus
aufenthalten im in und ausland zu fragen
dann sei es ratsam diese gezielt auf
resistenzen zu untersuchen
die vereinten nationen hatten
multiresistente keime übrigens schon
2016 als die größte und dringendste
gefahr überhaupt bezeichnet studien
zufolge sterbens schon jetzt jährlich
weltweit 700.000 menschen an infektionen
durch medikamenten resistente keime bis
2050 könnte diese zahl auf 10 millionen
opfer steigen das sagen zumindest
hochrechnung einer britischen
expertengruppe hat voraus im klartext
hieße dass dann mehr tote durch
resistente erreger als durch
krebserkrankungen besorgniserregend ist
dass auch die suche nach neuen
antibiotika alles andere als einfach ist
deswegen suchen forschungsteams weltweit
fieberhaft nach alternativen
große hoffnung setzen experten in
eiskalte bakterien fressen diese so
genannten fragen sind darauf
programmiert bakterien zu töten und das
mit einer zerstörerischen kraft den
laborversuchen kommen die bakterien
fressen sogar gegen multiresistente
keime an könnten fragen also die
menschheit tatsächlich vor dem
schlimmsten bewahren
dazu gibt es ein video hier auf klicks
um genau da antibiotika resistenzen
können fragen millionen vor dem sicheren
tod retten anklicken anschauen und
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren bis
dann
bleibt dran